Republican Senate candidate Adam laxalt  has conceded thank you for joining us at  noon I'm Heather Mills incumbent  Democrat Senator Catherine Cortez masto  has been projected to hold on to her  seat recent results showed the two were  separated by about 8 000 votes and today  laxalt released a statement on Twitter  saying in part quote this race and the  2022 election cycle didn't go as we  hoped but I am proud of the race we ran  that is why this morning I called  Catherine Cortez mastota congratulate  her on her win he goes on to say I am  grateful for the outpouring and  encouragement I have received and all  remain forever committed to our state  our country and our cause